[Music] The
occupation continued to put lasers on us, fire
gas bombs, and fire bullets from time to time.
We were taken, meaning the ground sat on the ground. As soon as he
stood up, one of the occupation soldiers present on the
ground opened fire during what happened. I can
confirm that the occupation deliberately targeted
the journalists directly. We were completely clear
to the occupation.  We are journalists. A believer was wearing a
jacket that makes it clear that he is a Palestinian journalist.
[Music]
We have become accustomed to these things. Our
first verse,
and of course the broadcasting process does not indicate
that there is hatred. [Music] [Music] Unfortunately, journalists are repeatedly targeted on a daily basis by the occupation, but it is clear that there is an escalation.
On targeting journalists
[music]